[Applaudissements]
elle croyait que je parlais d'elle je
parle pas que de vous sentez
un plaisir de faire une chronique à côté
de vous c'est vrai
aussi la semaine prochaine je suis
encore là
peut-être que vous découvrez la
chronique
alors vous vous serez pas là vous voyez
vas-y non peut-être que vous découvrez
la chronique chez vous on va revenir sur
les meilleurs moments des interviews
politiques de la semaine et il s'en est
passé des choses hein c'était l'éclate
j'ai remarcher était l'invité de
Télématin il a pas vu le temps patience
bon il a pas vu l'émission tout court le
gaëtank de calcium tout ce qu'on
commence à travailler avant
[Musique]
tout ces sujets
nous voyons bien que
Éric Zemmour était dans leur dépôt il
avait perdu sa boule de cristal mais
rassurez-vous il y a pas fallu très
longtemps pour la retrouver bonjour Éric
Zemmour bonjour sommes-nous les
somnambules de 2022 toujours difficile
de répondre à ce genre de question j'ai
pas de boule de cristal et on l'a
retrouvé
et vous verrez dans cinq ans dans 10 ans
il n'y aura plus que des femmes à la
France insoumise cinq ans plus tard il
n'y aura plus que des femmes racisées
comme ils disent dans 10 ans Clémentine
Autain dira que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
un homme de droite merci le visionnaire
Aurélien Pradier en détresse sur Sud
Radio à tel point qu'il a essayé d'en
voir un SOS avec ses yeux
[Musique]
vous êtes
donc face à une Retailleau eriki et donc
peut-être Virginie Calmels et comme une
bouteille lancée à la mer son SOS a
trouvé un destinataire presque à théveno
lui a répondu sur les 4 vécu de
l'Institut d'obsa 70% selon hélas je
cite plusieurs instituts Bruno Le Maire
était sur France Inter pour parler NRJ
et chauffage
tant que la température ne sera pas en
dessous de 19 degrés vous verrez plus
avec une cravate mais avec un col roulé
et je pense que ce sera très bien c'est
la manière la plus efficace de passer
l'hiver sans avoir à couper l'énergie
pour qui que ce soit facile à dire en
septembre mais j'ai hâte de voir ces
interviews cet hiver bonjour Bruno Le
Maire bonjour Nicolas
bonjour Bruno Le Maire bonjour Nicolas
bonjour Bruno Le Maire bonjour
[Applaudissements]
qui propose de ça quand même de mettre
un pull franchement non j'ai pas aimé
cette réaction c'est pas grave on
viendra ici aussi avec un petit peu
voilà
bon après la politique bah je me suis un
peu changé les idées sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est le retour de des
meilleures vidéos de la semaine c'est
Made in France c'est la météo des
réseaux
[Musique]
on s'agrandit un nouveau Spider-Man
débarque et sa promesse
allez on si vous avez un problème au
volant notez bien ce système D même si
on sait pas trop c'est une voiture ou
une lampe de chevet et la pièce et elle
est trop cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout celui qui galère à démarrer
gros affiche Hermès avec un une
rencontre digne des plus grands matchs
Champions League
un petit stylo qui fuit ça nous est tous
déjà arrivé après ça fait quand même
beaucoup à Vierzon
un truc qui fuit j'en ai plein les mains
mais c'est pas ça le plus gros problème
j'espère que vous avez de bon réflexe
pas comme ce gars en plein cours
il reviendra la semaine prochaine dans
l'applaudit très fort merci